good afternoon everybody and welcome Ian
Shapiro the director of the Macmillan
Center and I'm delighted to be welcoming
you here today for this joint venture
between Macmillan and the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences before
getting things off to a start let me
just remind everybody that there will be
a reception following this event up on
the second floor to which everybody is
invited it's it's really a great
pleasure for me to be able to introduce
this event today let me say a couple of
words about the American Academy it was
founded in 1780 doing the revolution by
John Adams James Bowden John Hancock and
others who helped establish the new
nation the Academy's founders believed
that a strong Republic must be grounded
in open discourse engaged scholarship
and informed and an informed an active
citizenry over time the American Academy
has expanded to include leaders in all
fields and disciplines many of whom
worked together through the Academy to
dress topics of both timely and abiding
concern the Academy now includes about
5,000 members around the world including
200 or so in the New Haven area it it
holds annual meetings around the country
and conducts research projects out of
its home offices in Cambridge
Massachusetts in the areas of Arts and
Humanities American institutions Science
and Technology education and global
security tonight's program is part of
the Academy's Morton L Mandel public
lecture series named in honor of Jack
Joseph and Morton Mandel foundations
generous support for the Academy it was
organized by the Academy's new haven
program committee a group of Yale based
Academy members that convenes periodic
discussions and research presentation
on issues of importance in partnership
with Macmillan I'm going to just
introduce our moderator Krystal beamster
and then turn things over to her and she
will introduce the panelists and talk
about how we're going to proceed she's a
professor in the department's of African
American Studies history and American
Studies so welcome to you all and thank
you crystal thank you and good afternoon
and welcome
I want to begin by thanking and the New
Haven Program Committee of the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences and the
Yale's Macmillan Center especially
Francis Rosen booth and Anne Shapira for
helping to organize this event this
evening now I have the honor and the
great pleasure of introducing two of my
colleagues professor David Bligh and
professor Robert Steptoe and and because
I do want us to be able to have a full
and lengthy lengthy conversation in
which you all get to participate and ask
questions I will keep my introductions
brief because I do I'll know that these
scholars really don't need an
introduction but I will attempt to to
give you a little bit of taste of who
they are
Robert Steptoe is the jaw is the John
and skiffs
professor of English about African
American Studies and American Studies at
Yale his he is the author of many
publications including a home elsewhere
reading african-american classics in the
Age of Obama blues as the lake a
personal geography and from behind the
veil a study of african-american
narratives this is also professor steppe
toast last semester teaching at Yale we
were able to celebrate him about a year
ago when many of his students came back
and I have to say I'm on the fourth
floor with Robert and it is going to be
really sad when he's not moving through
those halls I'm hoping he is not going
to give up his office anytime soon not
soon and and I want to turn to my
colleague I'm professor David Bligh he's
the class of 1954 professor of American
history and director of the Gilder
Lehrman Center for the Study of slavery
and abolition at Yale University he is
the author of numerous books as well
including a slave no more two men who
escaped to freedom race and reunion the
civil war in American memory beyond the
battlefield race memory and the American
Civil War and most recently frederick
douglass prophet of freedom which has
been awarded the Gilder Lehrman Lincoln
prize and the Bancroft prize and so
today we want to have a conversation
about Douglass as a writer a literary
scholar and artists as David's mammoth
biography of Douglass makes clear there
is much to discuss ranging from his
three autobiographies the novella heroic
slave to his hundreds upon hundreds of
short form political editorials and the
thousands of speeches he delivered in
frederick douglass prophet of freedom
professor black wrote the reason we
remember Douglass is because he found
the word and in professor step toes
introduction to Douglass's first
autobiography narrative of the life of
Frederick Frederick Douglass he wrote
somehow Douglass intuitively knew that
to write and craft his story as opposed
to telling it was to compose and author
himself both professor Bly and professor
Steptoe have argued that Douglass
Douglass's autobiography czar great
books with capital G and Steptoe wrote
that the narrative is a truly great
American book and blight wrote that
bondage and freedom is a great
autobiography so I was hoping we could
begin our Congress
sation by talking about what made
douglas such a brilliant writer more
specifically how douglas became a writer
his method are as Professor blight
refers to his style and motivations and
how he's contributed to American
literature more specifically and I know
that both professor blight and I'm
professor Steptoe can speak from their
disciplines as literary scholars and
historians but I also know that they're
both interdisciplinary scholars working
in at the intersection of
african-american studies history English
and American Studies so I'm hoping that
they will speak to what what how their
own methods speak and align with blight
us what I mean with Douglas as well
sorry anyway I'm gonna turn it over to
them and you can choose to engage that
question however you like let me first
of all welcome you all but jump right
into the question and it seems to me
that Douglass was an extraordinary
writer because of his relationship to
words and I'm I'm putting it in in that
sense because we're talking about
someone creating and also creating
himself through too inviting but also
through the spoken word one of the
things that I've been I've been thinking
about particularly after reading David's
latest book is Douglass's performance of
words yes the performance in terms of
writing all of the text but the
performance in terms of the speeches he
gave the would he would give at any
slavery relevance what he would do in
churches and so forth one thing that is
also very clear to me I said
got so much from biblical stories and
biblical language he found he found
images he found metaphors he found
rhythms and and so forth and certainly
one thing that he done from from from
the Bible were the various prophetic
stories and indeed one of the things I
hope that David will touch on is
something that he's written about and
that is Douglass being himself a prophet
and the ways in which he was a prophet
through his word mastery let me stop
there for now well first of all thank
you Ian and Francis and the American
Academy and crystal for coming to do
this and when Ian and Francis asked me
to do this I said yes I'd be thrilled to
do this but I want to do Robert Steptoe
I knew Robert was somewhere close to
teaching his last semester I don't know
if you why she will know this or not but
I started reading Roberts essays on
Douglass when I was in graduate school
he wrote an essay in particular which I
still quote it quoted in my edition of
the narrative he he true this was in the
70s I think I shouldn't have said that
but anyway he wrote an essay on
Douglass's narrative that argued how it
showed how the text was what he called a
story of ascendancy it was an ascendant
story from slavery to freedom and that
the rhythm of the book the movement of
the book the creation of the self in the
book the character called Frederick
Douglass is always ascending and I
didn't know what I was doing at that
point except trying to learn about
Douglass and he's right of course that's
Douglass his great skill as the
manipulative photo biographer that he
was yes always imposing the self on us
that he most wants us to use Douglass's
is Robert just said he's all about words
we wouldn't be here and we wouldn't even
be talking about it if it weren't for
the words millions of them thousands of
speeches 1,200 pages of autobiography
three autobiographies and then he
revises the third one a fourth time if
you're a biographer never trust anybody
who writes three autobiographies because
they are always there in front of you
imposing themselves on himself on you I
think it's good well I think it's good
to it it's great but but as a biographer
there's a lot left out okay for we lowly
historians there's a lot left out anyway
but words we might discuss here a bit
just how he came by literacy and when
when he ceases literacy which is what he
did as a boy and then as he grows into
an early teen discovers the Columbian
orator this this book of speeches but
especially this manual of oratory that
he
in his hands by the time he's 12 years
old the most important possession he
ever had in slavery and then gains a
further kind of literacy from just
gathering anything he could find a read
and then by listening to sermons that
sermonic language he gets that King
James language he gets in his head as a
kid first and then as a teenager and he
names four churches in Baltimore that he
attends while he's still a teenage slave
he not only seized literacy he
weaponized words good point it took him
time I mean this he doesn't you know
come out of slavery a fully-formed
orator and certainly not a fully formed
writer that takes time for anybody but
he was also so proud once he established
himself as a writer there was nothing he
was more proud of in fact there's a
letter he writes about his first
published article it's in the late fall
of 1844 he's just about to start to sit
down to write the narrative and his
little cottage up in the Lynn
Massachusetts and he writes to this
editor who's just accepted this short
article he's written and the letter ends
with a line that goes something like oh
but to write for a book well which was
his way of saying if I could write a
book and a lot of us in this room you
never forget writing your first book and
what it looks like and the altar you
make for it in your home or your
apartment or that's what I did I still
do this book isn't is up on the mantle
I'm sorry it is but but Oh to write for
a book it was and here was a very young
man 26 years old a former slave black
people weren't supposed to be people of
literacy people of literature could I
write a book could he ever and that
winter he sits down and writes the
greatest slave nurse yes
well you're absolutely right - to talk
about how he was very clear that it
wasn't enough to be able to read that
you needed to be able to to write as
well never said essay in in 1844 that
the first narrative comes out in 1845
and let us not forget that what he would
do soon thereafter
let's do actually start talking about a
newspaper and and couldn't wait to have
his own it couldn't could not wait to
have his own newspaper and to and and
indeed that came before my bondage in my
freedom and and so the writing was very
important in in that regard but I also
want to think about how he was also
creating himself if you will to through
the speaking that we've talked about
before one of the things that has been
on my mind lately and I really surprised
I hadn't really thought about it earlier
is that Douglass is speaking and writing
performing words creating himself
and when I say perform I'm also talking
about how he is dressing himself and we
know something about that from the
photographs and so forth that he's doing
all of this during the period in which
minstrelsy is being created and and is
coming up bow it in this country but she
o of course he hated it but think
exactly about how he was presenting
himself and the race different from what
was in the minstrel shows and and and
that and that that was that was a that
was something to see that was something
to
to contrast the I was just looking at
some of the dates the other day they the
first minstrel group interested really
their Virginia minstrels they created
they were created in 1843 now put that
date right with Douglass writing this
first autobiography in 1845 with him
speaking in the churches in New Bedford
and elsewhere and and creating the
newspaper and and and so forth so we we
have that that particular situation let
me add a couple other things to to to
all of this one thing that we learn in
my bondage and my freedom that he does
not write about in the first
autobiography was that sometimes shortly
after his mother passed away he
discovered that his mother was literate
and I just want you to think about what
that would mean to him that to discover
that that not only to discover that
there was an African American who was
literate but it was his mother and what
that would mean to him in terms of
actually on some level being part of the
next literate generation and so forth it
that that would mean something to him
that he just wasn't some kind of you
know anomaly or something and yes he was
let me just mention another elder who
was important in this story and again an
elder that he describes in my bondage of
my freedom
for the first time and that is uncle
Lawson a man a black man in Baltimore
that he meets when he gets to Baltimore
and one of the things I suggested in
writing about the narrative was it you
know in meeting uncle Lawson you know
this is an opportunity for him to if I
may put it this way
find a black father and to go to church
with that black father and to be
literate in those various ways with that
black father unbonded she calls him
father was yes in bondage she calls him
father that's terribly important he
encounters this Charles Lawson who was a
dreaming by day just drove a cart to try
to make a living but he was a Bible
fanatic and yet he wasn't fully literate
but when he discovered this teenage kid
who could read so well according to
Douglas he just sat him down hours and
hours and hours and hours and they would
read out loud the old testament dog was
you know he's not understanding the book
of Job if that's what he's not
understanding Isaiah yet he's not
understanding Jeremiah but he's reading
the cadence of that language is getting
into his head reading with this old man
who he came to love and otherwise who
said really not loud but that would mean
in terms of hearing the cadences not
really imagining them and as you read
them and let's talk a little more about
the orator I mean where does where does
this this brilliance for the oratory
come from again he's not born that way
but he's already doing this while he's a
slave he takes his Columbian order this
is an orator this amazing book this
compilation put together in 1797 by
Caleb Bingham a Connecticut schoolmaster
run it up up at Dartmouth and then in
Boston but anyway he published the
school reader in 1797
it went through 28 or odd editions over
75 years it was even published there's a
there's a Maryland Edition it was
published in a slave state most of the
speeches are out of the Enlightenment
tradition there's some speeches from
antiquity demosthenes is in there Cicero
is in there but it's mostly speeches
from the British and American
enlightenment that are about things like
liberty and equality and then the book
has a 20 page introduction that is a
manual on oratory it's a kind of a
how-to it it tells you how to gesture
with your arms and your shoulders and
your neck and then how to modulate your
voice from lower tones to higher atones
it it tells how to come to crescendos
and it has a whole section which is
really probably from Aristotle I'm not
so sure but it is all about how the
order must reach a moral message must
reach the heart the spirituality of the
audience Douglass used this manual to
teach his buddies on the Freeland farm
one of the places he's hired out to when
he's 17 and 18 years old on Sunday
afternoons they go off on a brush Arbor
and he was Fred it was the only literate
one among them according to his
testimony yes and he would teach them
oratory and then they'd recite so he's
already practicing and I think I mean I
say this in the book it's a kind of
speculation but what does every kid want
every kid wants to learn what you're
good at so you couldn't be better than
the other kids I mean you know right
dribble behind your back or oratory and
in this case it was oratory and by the
time he comes out of slavery at age 20
he's already practiced this so what's he
doing New Bedford by the time he's 21
the local AME Church has impress
formally preaching from the text and the
classic Protestant tradition and that's
where he gets discovered
finally by you know like two years later
by some garrison and abolitionists from
up in Boston and somebody says stolen on
board there's this young black guy down
at that AME Church and you better you
got to go see this kid and that's how he
gets discovered now he's still not fully
formed but when he finds when he does
get hired meager wages in 1841 by the by
the William Lloyd Garrison's
organization and he goes out on the
anti-slavery circuit at age 23 okay his
most famous speech in those first few
years and he's on the road all the time
with this troupe of abolitionists is the
speech that became known as the
slaveholders sermon this was Douglass
mimicking a slaveholding preacher using
those passages from the Bible slaves be
loyal to your masters and so on and so
forth and he would perform it he'd mimic
accents he'd prance around the stage and
it was such a good performance that
they'd be out on the circuit and
somewhere in Ohio and they abolitionist
meetings would always be organized
around speaking tour against a
resolution whatever the six resolutions
were that day and infrequently and I
have numerous press accounts of this
where someone in the audience does shots
out Fred do the sermon and this is okay
you know and he goes and he performed
performs the sermon and the audiences
would be weeping and laughing and
clapping and that's how he takes the
abolitionists oratorical platform by
storm at first he's kind of a second
fiddle to Abbey
Kelly who was this the first real star
woman of the abolitionist circuit but
within a couple of years he was the
Marquis
and it would always be a problem because
other abolitionists with time didn't
always like to appear with him well I
mean just too good speak to that [ __ ]
because I think if I remember your works
depth oh you really make the point about
the shift from telling the performance
of doing the abolitionists work right
and writing the book right and that you
you make a real concrete argument about
the power of the written word and what
he's able to do with that that he's not
able to do in those abolitionist
performances I'm wondering if you could
speak to what was at stake for him to
not just stick with telling it right and
those performances but what what is at
stake in the written word having it on
the page right and maybe it comes out of
those bad first book that he has that he
understands the stage could hold that in
his hands and say Here I am
well let me let me begin on that by
mentioning and perhaps reminding you
that famous moment in his autobiography
is when he talks about how there came a
point when someone and mine you an
abolitionist came up to him and said in
so many words you know you need to sound
more like a slave you need you know you
know you know you're you you're going
too far you know you get a little more
of the plantation into your into your
speech and all of that and you know I'm
not mistaken he's hearing that
specifically from garçon Ian and I'm
sure that that had something to do with
why he eventually moved away from the
garçon Ian's I mean there were lots of
reasons
putting political reasons and and so
forth but I would say among other things
that part of his response to people
saying to him why don't you sound more
like a slave was number one he wasn't
going to do that and number two he was
going to write and writing of course was
not what most slaves are doing but that
certainly is it's part of it David well
one thing that you mentioned is it is
the whole business about Douglass being
attracted not just to the Bible but
specifically to to the prophets yeah
Isaiah Jeremiah and so forth and and and
then being models for him in the certain
respects could you say something in this
conversation about Doug listen mm-hmm
prophecy
I'd love to we didn't plan that either
one of my problems in writing this book
over many years was coming to a
confidence confidence is huge in writing
as so many of you know we're even using
the word prophet prophets a big word and
you don't throw it around loosely but
Douglas writes and speaks in a language
that sometimes just hits you between the
eyes with a metaphor a single sentence
or a paragraph that transmits you
somewhere this there's so many Douglas
quotations you know the whole list of
Douglas quotations that people put
together now now the way I got
comfortable with that idea of prophecy
first of all you cannot read Douglass
carefully at all and not see the Bible
all over it especially the Hebrew
prophets he could not write a speech
without something generally speaking
there are a few exceptions without
something from Isaiah Ezekiel Jeremiah
or Amos and others sometimes the New
Testament but usually the Old Testament
where Douglas learned his storytelling
and the cadences of his voice are in the
stories of the Old Testament he made
Exodus his own story this this hardly
makes him unique the Americans did this
all the time he made Exodus his own
story the story of his people and the
story of his nation Americans have been
doing that ever since they've been
Americans but the way I got finally
comfortable with this was by asking a
few theologian friends of mine one of
them is sitting here Jim ponent I'm
sorry Jim you're here in the front row
so there were others I asked like Don
Shriver who's a dear friend III don't
have any formal theological training and
I had wished many times in the course of
reading this book that I somehow could
get a year off to do nothing but read
theology I asked but I asked a few
theologian friends one of them was Jim
rabbi Jim and after laughing at me I
think when I asked so what should I read
on the Old Testament you ask a rabbi
what you should read on the Old
Testament and after a while Jim said
you've got to read Abraham Heschel
should read barbered alter you should
read this you should read that sure read
heschel and I did Heschl's great book
especially called the prophets in the
1950s and the first long chapter of that
book is a hundred different ways of
defining a profit and Heschl's template
of course is the Hebrew prophets but
he's also reflecting on modern prophets
and the mecca long story short what
heschel helped me understand is that a
prophet is not just somebody who
predicts prophets are often wrong
prophets don't just predict prophets as
heschel says
are human but they are those people who
speak in words one ought to speak or
write in words one octave higher than
most of us can comprehend and they find
those words in the right timing and
place to shatter us and then there are
many other definitions I took from
Heschel and from Walter Brueggemann and
from Robert alter who wrote a terrific
book about how the King James version of
the Bible is kind of the American text
of the 19th century that all American
writers owed I think of Melville think
of Lincoln owed so much of their prose
style there their message in their prose
to the King James style of language
now what Douglass would do on and off is
sometimes direct uses of biblical
quotations sometimes just paraphrases
sometimes just single phrases out of
quotes I actually brought a couple to
use if you really want to hear them but
what Douglas found in the Old Testament
was storytelling
and metaphor and ancient authority
ancient authority and power for the
claims he's trying to make on this
American experiment which is failing and
then he's gonna live long enough to see
it failing again so I made a big deal at
one of the biggest themes in my
biography is how how steeped Douglas was
in the Bible and how his rhetoric and
his politics oh so much to the
storytelling of the Old Testament I even
did a survey at one point of several of
the major speeches which books the
Testament got used the most Isiah always
comes out first maybe it's because it's
the longest book in the Bible I don't
but Jeremiah was second yeah and
Frederick Douglas was the American
Jeremiah and the fullest sense and I
think even self-consciously so although
he I know of no time when he actually
called himself that I'm glad he didn't
if he called himself that it would have
been a little awkward hello I'm the
American Jeremiah yeah don't do that
anyway I could go on and on about well
he would use super examples of their the
famous line in Isaiah there's no rest
for the wicked
which comes out in many different ways
and forms and uses he used that over and
over and over on slaveholders or anybody
else he wanted to shatter with language
you sorry no no religion so many
wonderful things actually you're
reminding me of something I made a note
of here today that I found in your book
that that I'd like to share with people
and also your comment about it for black
Americans Exodus is always contemporary
history always past and present that
really struck me Exodus is always
contemporary and part of the reason it
strikes me is because it certainly was
always contemporary for Douglass among
others but in fact it's contemporary for
us now
he's an exiled son he's an exiled son
over and over and over and when he
thinks he's transcended that he
sometimes learns he hasn't yes
and of course among other things
thinking about it historically it gives
the Kansas Exodusters oh yeah uh yeah
gives that story of a particular place
in history he got on the wrong side of
that one though in some ways I mean he
yes he sort of lost that debate well
that's another story
no no no I know exactly what it was
called yeah it was called it and it's
another moment when exodus was to burn
yeah yeah for him
another thing you you mentioned which
struck me and that was were you write
about how Douglass employed all manner
of blood metaphors for the nature of
african-american history and especially
in the second autobiography especially
in the second autobiography but you know
consider such phrases is you know
history that might be traced with a
trail of blood or here's this one and
you know him directly quoting Douglass
slavery put thorns under the feet under
feet already bleeding their thorns under
feet already bleeding and and and and
the blood metaphor is gone and it's
in a word graphic it's especially me as
a literary scholar you've probably
already written this but in the first
autobiography of 1845 he portrays
famously a fight he has with Edward Co V
the overseer to whom he's hired out and
it's a pivot of the book no question
he's he spends about 11 pages and I just
looked this up today I don't walk around
knowing all these things he spends about
11 pages on it in the narrative he
spends 35 pages on it in bondage and
freedom 10 years later when he's 37
years old in that right dead in the
midst of the political crisis over
slavery when he's broken from the moral
suasion Esguerra so nians he's embraced
palette to the politics of anti-slavery
and he's even begun to embrace the
possible uses of violence yes and in the
two pages where he actually describes
the combat with Edward Co V he spends 35
pages on his time with Co V the 15 uses
of the word blood we're getting very
literary here but why not
this this is a Douglass now who is using
autobiography to attack not just now the
hypocrisy of the American nation but
it's very existence and he's in effect
you know he doesn't know what's coming
he's a prophet who can't or can't
predict any better than the next
but blood metaphors are all over that
book and heaven ends with one yeah which
he didn't quite do ten years earlier no
when he's a he's a moral suasion asti's
supposed to be pacifist under Garrison's
now I'm not I'm not saying that you know
he's right now that he's not a pacifist
it's just that he's he's scrambling he's
desperate by the middle of the 1850s for
solutions that are out of grasp and yet
he
uses the literary form he makes the
literary act into a political act yes
through autobiography yes as well as any
American who wrote a memoir in the 19th
century perhaps any American who's ever
written a memoir one of the things that
it occurs to me is you remind us of all
these things is that and I I realized
this is going to sell in at first a
little cute but Douglas is telling went
by learned a particular meaning and
substance for what I'm going to call the
V words victory violence and the vote oh
that's good you should have been
advising Douglas he could have he could
have he could have took that on the road
he did in certain ways yes well never
forget a time in Rochester oops well a
great autobiography is about loss about
the hopeless but necessary quest to
retrieve and control a past that forever
slips away memory is both inspiration
and burden method and subject the thing
one cannot live with or without Douglas
made memory into art brilliantly and
mischievously employing its authority
its elusiveness its truth and its charms
I'm wondering if you could talk a little
bit and you write about this if you
could talk a little bit about what makes
what makes Douglass's second biography
so brilliant and how is he using memory
not only as a method but as a strategy
well first of all thank you for reading
the book so carefully wow did I write
this while bondage and freedom is four
times as long as the narrative he's
writing it when he's 36 and 37 years old
he's a much more mature writer by now
and by the way the writer just a quick
aside and I'll come right back to that
in case we leave the oratory behind
every major speech of Douglass's life
all the lasting great speeches are in
the form of a text they're written
they're not he didn't just walk into the
halls and blow out the lights with an
eloquence you know they're written down
and by the 1870s and 1880s they're in
typescript this wasn't this wasn't an
orator who just spun it off the top of
his head in fact I'm absolutely
convinced like a lot of us maybe Douglas
didn't know what he thought about
something till he went to his desk and
he wrote it exactly and he's a writer
anyway bondage and freedom is a much
more political autobiography that that
sounds kind of vague but but he's
writing it now in 54 55 when he's become
a political abolitionist he's embraced
first a Free Soil party then the Liberty
Party and he's now trying to understand
how to embrace the new Republican Party
he's come to believe slavery cannot be
destroyed without somehow altering law
political institutions and political
will he doesn't exactly know how that's
gonna happen yet and he's not
comfortable yet with the Republicans but
it's it's a it's a it's a book that's
arguing with American voters yes
secondly he's begun to embrace violence
possible uses of violence he never had a
theory of just how violence was supposed
to overthrow slavery and no one should
try to impose one on him he had a long
relationship with John Brown by my count
they met 11 times but he had the great
good sense not to join John Brown in
1859 so there is a the bondage and my
freedom reads at times as his story as
anticipation of possible violence in the
country it's his own story employed to
give this Jeremiah attic warning now of
the terror to come if the country can't
which is exactly what he's argued in the
famous fourth of July speech just a few
years earlier you know in a single in
his greatest speech the rhetorical
masterpiece of American abolition but
bondage and freedom also is an updating
it's ten more years of his life and it's
the transformation he wrote the first
narrative before he goes to England you
know he's got to tell you the story of
how Ireland Scotland and England
transformed him and it did brought him a
whole new set of friends which it did
supporters financial supporters from
he's never giving full credit to
particularly to julia Griffiths who
became his assistant editor and made his
writing life possible in some ways but
he's also got this this emergence of a
political thinker now and a
constitutional thinker to represent and
he is doing that through telling you the
tales of his life it's also still and
this would be my last point about this
it's still it's still the voice and now
the voice of a much more insurgent kind
of revolutionary voice it's it's a it's
a much more mature kind of heroic
revolutionary voice warning the country
and it's why it's so different from what
will become his third autobiography some
30 years later life and times
yeah well that heroic revolutionary
voice gives way into a it's a terribly
important book so full of information
but it gives way to a kind of a
flattened Gilded Age old man summing up
his life and name-dropping 10 years
later which is mostly about how famous I
am and I went to Europe and I saw the
pyramids and and that's it's it's still
full of great stuff if you're the
biographer but it's not not the heroic
writing of those first two
autobiographies but but one last thing
about my bondage and my freedom he
launches it in 1855 five thousand copies
sold in the first two days you know
which shows you something about
Douglass's notoriety and fame and it
sold 18,000 copies in the first three
years out that that's incredible in the
19th century for a book that's four
hundred and sixty pages long and he sold
it for a dollar and he took he he would
take two of his sons with him on the
road given speeches and they would Hawk
the book among the audience the guy was
a marketer too he had to be how he's
making a living and by the way from 1841
when he goes on the lecture circuit to
1877 when he gets his first federal
appointment in the District of Columbia
from President Hayes he never made a
dime in his life except by his voice in
his pen and his British and a few
American financial supporters he had
some patrons he didn't always give him
credit
except privately but he never he never
had a job I always tell my students you
know being an abolitionist it's not a
good career move
it wasn't any there were no salaries and
abolitionism I'm gonna go back for a
minute to the business about the blood
imagery in the blood metaphor this is
one thing that I forgot to mention when
I was talking about it before it was
sort of obvious that he was he was
talking about how people were harmed and
and and so forth there's fascinating the
early moment in my bondage of my freedom
when he mentions a white woman by the
name of Miss Lucretia who was there in
Maryland you really liked when he was
young I mean is a child young man so
forth and he remembers her for two
distinct reasons number one this is a
woman who would give him a piece of
bread and butter every now and then
especially if he came up to her window
and saying the other thing I said at one
point he's got in on some kind of battle
fight believe what that another young
man named Ike and and he was all bloody
and so forth and he specifically tells
us that Miss Lucretia was the one who
brought him inside and cleaned him up so
that is another side to her to all of it
there are the people who spill your
blood but they're also the people who
clean you up and and miss Lucretia is
remembered in those terms it's a it's a
very particular way to turn to and there
are ways Robert in which he came to
trust women in his life that he did not
necessarily trust men
true me that's not always an easy claim
to make but he developed trusting
relationships with women more than he'd
ever did with men yes and I may not be
just Lucretia that brought that but he
does say that's the first white person
who ever invited him inside that's right
about the blood sort of metaphor I mean
he opens narrative with the blood of his
aunt right the first narrative yes
Esther and I'm wondering if you could
speak to that
and how that gets worked out in his
writing and his politics well I mean
begin by saying that when you think of
the full range of his career and what he
would write it's very striking that they
that the first autobiography would would
begin with what happened to two on
Hester that that kind of atrocity what
would be there you might even say it's
it's even sort of a scripted moment you
know Here I am I'm supposed to tell you
about slavery
I mean begin straight off with with
withheld my my aunt Hester was was
beaten and so forth by his own master by
his own by his own master and who might
be his father
yes yes what I was trying to suggest a
minute ago is that is that when he
begins the next autobiography and and
then the last one he doesn't begin with
on Hester mm-hmm and although
interestingly enough
I'm thinking now in the beginning of my
bondage and my freedom he does once
again begin with family yeah and he
begins with the grandmother and
grandfather that he that he lives with
this grandmother being the mother of
five daughters one of the daughters
being his mother and all five daughters
off on some plantation somewhere none of
them are there and that's that's where
he he begins with begins the the second
the second narrative he's an orphan and
I know if any time you ever used the
term you know I am an orphan but it is a
central fact of his life and this is
where the loss idea that you brought up
all memoir is about retrieving loss I
mean our lives are lost somehow every
day and if we write on them what we're
trying to retrieve it and then
manipulate our reader at the same time
but he has a great deal of loss and I
think tremendous scarring in his soul
psyche mentality whatever we want to
call it I don't try to over psychologize
that but he experienced or saw every
kind of savagery slavery could wreak on
PBS and he comes out of slavery with a
tremendous rage and I've always thought
I don't know wonder how you think about
this we're here talking about literacy
and the power of words his great good
luck is that he became such a genius
with words because he could process that
rage in language yes the rest of his
life like nobody else if he couldn't
where would he what would he do with
that rage where would he that's that's
an excellent point because you know we
all know outrage can shut people down
but Douglas found an energy in it any
and he found an eloquence in it and I'm
glad you make the point about him being
that an orphan I mean what really goes
on in the early pages of that second
derivative it's just how the rift of
family he is yeah yeah no eruptive home
any conception of loneliness and and
finding out that you know in a year or
two he's going to be taking on a 12 mile
walk and where he will become a slave on
the plantation of the man who actually
owns him and you know part of what he
tells him that story is how his
grandmother's role in all of this is to
take him there and then once she's
certain that he's playing with his
siblings and his cousins she'll leave
and indeed he finds out that she's left
when one of the children come up to him
and says you know free food granny's
gone
granny's gone and you know with that
even begins the rest of his children
abandoned abandoned which leads me to
thinking I mean don't know exactly how I
want to put this yet but it needs me to
to think a bit about the family that he
and anna-marie created for children what
they were trying to do now one of the
things that is gratifying was the whole
idea that they created a family and they
were married altogether in 44 years
before she passed away
on the other hand you know as you learn
his life story you realize how little he
was at home you know some of these
speaking tours were taker
year-and-a-half or more so it's a little
disconcerting to me to think about how
he created a family and what wasn't
there yeah I got into all kinds of cult
of socks on that issue that I spare you
I kept asking a couple of friends you
know to read this and read that for me
and because I was calling him the absent
father abandoning his children and one
friend who said oh go lighter on him
that's what men had to do in the 19th
century by the way on this question of
the white plantation just before we
leave that and open it up to you I hope
there's always been a lot of mystery
about Douglass's autobiography Xand one
sense like you know what maybe is he
making up and whatnot we know a great
deal about what he made up and did not
make up because of particularly of a
book by Dickson Preston called the young
Frederick Douglass published in 1980 but
also I had this I had a number of
incredible experiences out on the
Eastern Shore and that the people who
now own the white plantation which is
stole their same house some same
outbuildings are the fifth generation
direct descendants of the Lloyds they
have now finally embraced Douglass
they're proud of the fact of the most
important person from the state of
Maryland in American history was a slave
on that on that land and the kitchen
house in which he watched his aunt
Hester Beaton is now a very fancy
remodel department but the fireplace is
still there and so is the crawlspace
next to it where he hid
and I've been privileged to stay there
twice sitting in front of the fire
reading the stories from White House and
one day one at the Times I was there a
year or two ago
there's among the many many nature
metaphors in the autobiographies there
are lots of them whether it's their
water metaphors or fowl metaphors or
flowers and so on his Douglass
describing walking around the WHI
plantation when he's seven years old and
always watching the black birds the
flocks of black birds and imagining
himself on their wings and I would
always land in the trees and then away
they go and he wishes he's on their
wings so one morning very early I went
out for a walk and there they were
thousands of blackbirds I thought he
didn't make that up and then there's the
sailing ships on the Chesapeake yes make
that up either amazing moment when you
realize in literature that some
metaphors are not just metaphors
they are metaphors but they're not just
metaphors at least to a lowly historian
that ain't just a metaphor anymore you
know there they were and they were
incredibly loud and he talks in the
narrative about how those blackbirds the
cacophony of those black birds could
take over the plantation and silence
everything else and I thought yeah
so that's memory put to the service of
the power of autobiography as persuasion
and anyway he had an uncanny memory it
isn't of course always accurate but
nobody's memory is always accurate but
one of the things you have to do if you
study this guy is you you have to try to
understand if you can what do we
actually remember
childhood and he engaged in a great deal
of effort to reconstruct that childhood
and he gets almost every name accurate
he gets places accurate timing accurate
the storytelling he puts it in is his
own question but I think what you said
David is important and I wanted to read
one last quote that it lines up with
something that a Robert rode in the
narrative which is Douglass is
remembering remembering places and names
and in some ways fundamental ways
wrestling control of those memories by
handling them and in that sense owning
the names of the people who were once in
effect
who wants in effect owned him and so I
think it's a nice way to kind of it in
that portion yeah quick along those
lines you you mentioned how he mentions
the names and so forth that was a very
important feature of that first
autobiography you know he you names
names yes I mean they it is in that
sense if I may is the a tell-all book
[Music]
you know he names the plantation owners
he he he names the overseers and and of
course there's that wonderful wonderful
moment no that's a wonderful but it's
wonderful in terms of how it's written
when he tells us about that evil
overseer by the name of mr. severe and
that's the guy's name and you think it's
a Toni Morrison not
and it's not actually I'm there's not a
guy named gore yes and and yeah
and of course Gore the man who replaced
severe was fired because he wasn't
profane enough and so they brought in
somebody named gore but he has to be
fiction yes but here's the thing about
but about severe I read maybe you're the
one his name was actually and I'm not
sure how he pronounced it but it was SE
v IE are and but in Douglass's narrative
it's severe and rebelling by intention
yeah talk about intentional right I just
want to mention one other thing and
maybe it's something that some of you
want to join in on David among others
has mentioned that Frederick Douglass
was the most photographed American of
the 19th century and I think there lots
of things to think about why that
happened how that came to be why indeed
he wanted to be photographed and so
forth and let me just end on that and
throw that out as something that we
might talk about something you might
talk about and of course we want to hear
anything else that you want to bring up
we have one person with Mike and if
you're gonna act you make sure you speak
into the mic if you're gonna ask a
question and I'll call on you if you
raise your hand
well you just introduced a na
sure hi I'm Jennifer thank you professor
is very interesting I wanted to ask
about sort of this going off of the
metaphor in the use of blood and the
idea of the move of the the three V's
you referenced towards violence this
need that he has of redemption and sort
of the as the war the civil war begins
really just putting down with such
severity this slave power that he
references professor blight you you
write that he fashioned the apocalyptic
fate of the Confederacy and I thought
that was a really interesting way to put
that my question is is how in in your
both of your opinions does sort of the
lack of that apocalyptic fate change him
and as he moves forward obviously into
political positions how can we see that
sort of affecting him as the writer as
the orator and as a person Wow
thank you well he actually experienced
what he had most finally hoped for in
the Civil War
not that he predicted it all but a
bloodbath in which the United States
would be destroyed and reinvented
redeemed if you like now one of the
biggest themes of his life and I make it
a huge theme in the book is what happens
to the old radical outsider an
abolitionist always outside of power
always knocking on the doors
politically who now lives to see his
cause triumph in the middle of his life
he's in his 40s and then is gonna live
another 30 years to see that triumph all
but betrayed erased eroded whatever you
want to call it defeated what happens is
the old radical outsider who becomes a
political insider Douglass is our
prototype
and when we can name many many other
people in the 20th or 21st century who
fit this category in the wake of the
civil rights movement and other places
in the think of a Nelson Mandela whoa
you know there are ways in which
Douglass once he becomes an insider in
Washington DC or is trying to be when he
moves there in 1872 it gets his first
federal appointment by 1877 and gets
three more federal appointments from
different presidents makes deals and
some compromises to a certain degree but
he never ever gave up on that vision
that history is sometimes driven by
these apocalyptic ruptures that too is
an old testament vision of history
mm-hmm
that's worried that that's one of the
places he gets it from he also got it
from abolitionism it's all over
abolitionism he learned some of that
from Garrison in fact so his problem
here by let's say the 1870s and 1880s is
he's trying to defend reconstruction as
it's being defeated he's trying to
defend the 14th and 15th of amendments
as they're being erase who wrote it any
race by the Supreme Court by 1883 he's
trying to defend the Republican Party
which he never gives up on that is less
and less and less a political
organization interested in black civil
and political rights he does attack the
Republican Party at times and then he
works like hell for them in election
years because he has nowhere else to go
it's a series of very difficult
pragmatic deals he's making with the
history he's living and he takes a
pillar ring from the next generation of
black leadership yes with whom he has
some pretty ugly rivalries and I find
that period of Douglass's life in some
ways the most fascinating of all because
it's the most human and modern but he
still believed that history is full of
these ruptures
maybe by some divine intervention maybe
just by the forces that humans create he
could never tell you exactly how it came
about but he employed all the biblical
language necessary to make the case even
into old age my name is Mike they're
taping as thanks so much I'd like to go
back to Robert's idea about being
photographed the most during the 19th
century the being photographed yes and
that made me think of what David said
when Douglas would make a speech and
have his two sons with the books and you
know pitching the books to the to the
public how marketing savvy he was and I
think it has to do you know that the
photographs I think he realized probably
the the power of communication through
visual through through the image not
just the auditory where on his writing
yes and he wanted to show a the the
picture of a black American who was very
distinguished who's you know with with a
lot of grace with a lot of aura to
everybody possible that's his marketing
savvy well it became almost like an
expertise I think your points are very
good and and and an accurate I would I
would say that one thing that was was
going on I said it was he was presenting
broadly speaking an image of the race
but he was also presenting himself
there is a way in which how you pose how
you dress how you comb your hair and on
the meth so that for a photograph that
is personal that is autobiographical
then that it is a personal narrative
Douglas in his later years felt that
there wasn't enough attention to people
who were in on some level making it who
who had a house who had a kitchen you
know who could actually put on some
pretty nice clothes for Sunday all that
kind of thing and he just felt that and
and of course he was criticized for this
but he felt that there was just too much
attention to the sharecroppers and the
people in the fields and whatnot when
Douglas appears in one of these
photographs he is not a man in the field
and and and that was that was a very
very particular message now another
thing to think about is that I can't
think of a a book that came out that
didn't have one of his photographs oh
yeah I mean and so that the front is
part of what's going on here is that you
you know you have the narrative but you
have the image as well
and and and he's asking you to to read
both and to enter and to put that
together over the last couple decades
they've been
really some marvelous work done on the
photographs of Douglas and I I just
recommend it if any of you are
interested that you owe Google whatever
and just just look at what's out there I
can't help but think about you know
Sojourner Truth and her even dry and she
says I sell the shadow to support she's
selling her image which is really a kind
of you know constructed image of black
middle-class she's got a book and
reading glasses and we know that she
can't read great question I know I know
of no case of him actually selling his
photographs
he sold his books now what he did do
when he he founds a second newspaper in
Washington DC in 1872 the new national
era which he and his sons published for
three years and tell the one under and
he lost a lot of money on it but they
would the newspaper sold images of
Toussaint L'Ouverture and sometimes also
I wouldn't have been Martin Delany
because he had a big falling out with
Delaney they sold other but they they
sold images of Tucson because tonight
was such a symbolic figure by then
employ communities but and he sold his
books I don't know of any case he may
have he may have gone out and peddled
them but and once it ad I mean this is
later on though wasn't he need
representative of Haiti oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah
he was u.s. minister to Haiti and then
the representative the nation of a
Chicago world by the way if you don't
know it or have it and you got space on
your coffee table there's a terrific
book called picturing Frederick Douglass
but three intrepid editors John Stauffer
Zoe trident Celeste beignet which is all
that well like that we found too since
it was published but has a hundred and
sixty-two excellent photos of Douglass
and a whole lot of other images on
murals and it's it's a visual history of
Douglass it's an absolutely stunning
book it's the book I have it just came
up a couple years ago it's an amazing
and they found lots of new photographs
by scouring the country including this
amazing on that I put on my edition of
bondage and freedom which was found in a
Kansas City Art Museum and they had
never displayed it it's this stunning
profile of Douglass from 1857 I've never
been displayed how did you not display
this even I was thinking of some of your
comments on on Douglas and Scripture and
how John Collins the scripture scholar
once said to me there was hardly any
messianic eye movement in the years
coming up to Jesus time that was not
violent and and I remember sort of
sorting through Isaiah once and you
could see this sort of restorationist
vision which was peaceful and the Lions
was laid out with the lambs and then
these very violent remarks so I can see
how both Brown and Douglas would would
would feed themselves with this kind of
thinking but they went in different
directions even though they knew each
other hmm
and I'm wondering was it because
Douglass simply was political and brown
wasn't or
was there something about their own
appropriation in terms of their own
ideology that they took in how they
synthesized scripture that made the
difference well I want to be careful
because John Brown is in the room here
Norman performs John Brownback here so I
want to be careful with this don't to
stimulate any hi Norman how you doing
they have very different temperaments
very different temperaments and Douglas
as he said himself was far less the
warrior and Douglas famously said John
Brown was by far more valuable dead than
he'd ever been alive that's harsh but
politically and in terms of historical
memory he's probably right John Brown
could die for the slave I could live for
the slave Douglass said and in my living
I did not live up to what he did
Douglass made the utmost of the martyred
John Brown and that Douglass understood
was his best mode to make a literary use
of John Brown he did it the rest of his
life in fact when Douglass went to
Europe tour and he had hoped it would be
a vacation for 11 months with his second
wife Helen and he kept getting asked to
give speeches the speech they tended to
all what was the speech on John Brown
because of the fame of John Brown across
the world I want her to know about that
story Douglass by 1859 was looking for
possible uses of violence but where he
parted ways with John Brown is when he
found out that the attack was gonna be
on Harpers Ferry right the largest
federal Arsenal until that point in time
and he learns that somewhere in late 58
or early 59 until that point in time
Douglass was deeply involved with Browns
conspiracy as long as that conspiracy
was about the idea of establishing what
was a kind of militarized Underground
Railroad Brown called a subterranean
passageway the way Douglass came to
understand
that was gonna be this series of forts
and bands of men that we're gonna funnel
sleighs out of the upper south and
somehow to freedom and cause caused
havoc for the country Douglass was
pretty much on board with that believe
it or not until he found out Brown was
planning to attack the largest Arsenal
in the country and he said I'm out of
here
so it's it's they're different
temperaments Douglass had become a
political pragmatist by then too
he's trying to make a way in this world
of anti-slavery politics he's not yet
the warrior the brown already was from
his work in Kansas chapter 15 in my book
it's a long chat one of the longest
chapters in the book on that
relationship between them it's
incredible and fascinating and difficult
[Music]
professor Steptoe I know in your
autobiography in America class you teach
the narrative alongside Harriet Jacobs
incidents in the life of a slave girl
yes um how do you teach those two book
texts together and what what do you hope
your students get from that week well
let me just begin with some fundamental
features of the situation I offer both
of them because I want to make sure that
I offer a narrative by a man as well as
a narrative by by a woman another key
thing is to offer a narrative before
1850 and a narrative after 1850 and that
is to say before and after the Fugitive
Slave Act there's
much too to look at in in in in that
regard
oh they're just other things as well
including what the different experiences
they have in escaping slavery and what
they escaped to I would just be obvious
and say that Douglass is no Bedford is
very different from Harriet Jacobs is in
New York and and and their experience is
there and of course just going back to
to gender let us not forget that
how many Jacobs not just a woman she's a
mother and one of the things that we
look at carefully is what it meant for
her to be a slave mother and how was she
lived with that and so forth there's
also an important thing to look at in
terms of in terms of family we've
already talked today about Hell Douglass
was was less an orphan
you know he saw his mother a couple
times all that kind of stuff with Jacobs
we we have so much to think about in
terms of her relationship not just with
their children but with her grandmother
and all of those things that are that
are going on so those are things that
we're talking about I let me just say
that in in my autobiography course the
discussion isn't just about Douglass and
Jacobs I begin the course with Mary
rowlandson Indian captivity narrative
and of course one of the things too to
talk about there is rowlandson and
Jacobs as captive mothers and what to
see there and and how to put that how to
put that together also with all of these
books were just meeting them the whole
question of literacy and how literacy
plays a role in and how people survive
how people gain gain a kind of freedom
what kind of what I'm gonna call
mischievous strategies
literacy might think of bring about
Jacobs has a wonderful good time
arranging for letters that she's written
to be somehow another transported to New
York or even to Canada and then and then
mailed to North Carolina so that number
one quite quite people in North Carolina
will think that she's in New York or or
Canada when in fact you know she's in
her grandmother's attic when Douglas is
remembering his escape later he says
right before he writes it now for mich
d'If one thing I question Bianca one
thing I do mention I mean it it's not
really a parent and in in the in their
narratives but but you know Douglass and
Jacobs did overlap in Rochester for
almost a year and indeed the building
where his newspaper was on the first
floor was the same building that Jacobs
was
pursuing any slavery activities on the
second floor and he pretty much ignored
her on that note I won at first I want
to let folks know there is a reception
on the second floor and everybody's
invited to attend and to continue the
conversation but before we close I would
like to thank professor Bly and
professor Steptoe for a wonderful
conversation
[Applause]
[Music]